I feel like I'm experiencing Japan right
now at like 10 because I can't speak
yeah because one I'm in Tokyo so like
that's you know there's so much more
yeah but also uh because I can't speak
Japanese right so in in many respects I
feel like I'm literally for the first
time in my life because I've been in
Western Europe a lot like I grew up in
Turkey you know I live in America now
all around America I visited
I feel like a [__] alien like I feel
like I'm an alien that just landed on a
on you know another planet yeah that
just kind of really looks like my Planet
yeah with people that kind of look a lot
like me as well but I can't understand
anything right and it's so shocking
because like with the Latin alphabet you
really take it for granted oh go
anywhere long you go anywhere else like
you can still kind of make sense of like
what you go to Germany I don't I don't
speak German but like I can make sense
of like what I'm looking at yeah but
with like kanji I'm like what the [__]
what there's so much it's like blocks of
text I'm like what am I looking at it's
like it like hurts my brain and yet it's
still so much fun at the same time so
I'm like I'm thinking like you know if I
learned even a little bit of Japanese
which I feel like is how it starts oh
yeah like it's like you know when you
were being like whoa white boy swag I'm
like this is just a script yeah I've
gone to Starbucks so much coffee I know
every single dial
you should make a YouTube compilation
yeah I was like what is white boy
swagging he was talking about uh you
know the guy who goes is it Loud Chinese
and then they go all the Chinese people
go like whoa oh yeah yeah and then when
you saw that in Japan it doesn't work no
no oh you speak Japanese good as you
[__] [__] yeah you get any hunger
jokes
but like you know they don't they don't
freak out because they're not like um
like I don't know they're not like
characters
well well I don't think that the Chinese
people are like I think it's just like
Faking It for the most part yeah yeah he
orders in perfect fluid Mandarin blow
shopkeeper's mind it's like okay yeah
I because for some reason [__] I was
on that stream with you and someone
uploaded the clip and then the comments
were roasting me because they were like
he's literally just saying Japanese
English words
but it's so sick because like when you
speak Japanese one your voice drops okay
and two you have a list he said I had a
lisp yeah
yes you do slander no you know
everyone's waiting for Speed I don't
know you don't you don't have a list
normally when you're speaking English
but when you speak Japanese you're like
uh
my Japanese is more closer to I think
like my Thai accent than my Japanese
accent because when I speak Thai my
voice goes like up like two octaves I
don't know why I think it might just be
easier for a tonal language that it goes
up to octaves
um well yeah I've heard my Japanese like
my voice gets a lot higher when I speak
Japanese yeah but like when you say it
you don't notice it yeah what about with
you
in Turkish yeah
um definitely yeah people say I sound
like way more aggressive let's just took
it yeah yeah I guess maybe that's just
the language yeah like I'll be I'll I'll
say like you know I love you to my mom
or something in Turkish people like what
the [__] like why are you yelling
yeah like how do you appear like that it
doesn't sound like that it was about
like okay I'll kiss you mom you know
yeah yeah that's how you say like I see
you
um but Japan is the opposite yeah Japan
is Japan is like
I'll kill you yeah it's like oh my God
yeah yeah people say things very polite
but they'll like they'll literally be
saying it but they won't even be saying
bad things but they'll be the context of
what they're saying is like I will
[__] murder you yeah for me I feel
like because because of watching so much
anime and also because I speak Turkish
when I say things in Japanese I feel
like I'm saying it wrong like I was like
and it's like that's not how you're
supposed to say bye I don't think you
know it's not like Yakuza right yeah
you could probably have a slightly
easier time picking Japanese out because
you're bilingual yeah maybe yeah it
helps yeah
um there's a lot of similarities because
I mean I want white boy swag like you
you can get a man honestly you can get
it yes you do
do you think Tokyo would be better if it
focused a little bit more on making it
like more Foreigner friendly or do you
think it's like this is no this is it I
don't think I mean I think like ease of
access is good like at least use like
Latin alphabet in places yeah but I
don't think roads but I don't think they
should do that I don't think they should
because I've always had this like really
interesting thought because you know I
come from Thailand and we've made our uh
We've made our you know cities very very
easy to like visit and very foreign and
friendly and I'm like we try to keep as
much as the culture as we can but there
are some things like you know Bangkok
isn't even like the Thai name of like
Thailand
um sorry Bangkok isn't the Thai name of
the city
um it's actually grunteer which which is
harder to say for yeah westerners which
is actually not the full name oh yeah
isn't it the name of Thailand like super
[__] law I think it's actually like
the longest city name yeah in the world
he knows all about that [__] bro yeah oh
that's not the longest city but it's
just a long name so yeah dude come on
that
foreign
so okay so I think I can remember the
Thai full name for Bangkok
so it is
I'm serious I am serious what could you
be saying in that lens it's basically
describing the city so so you know you
know how like in you know you know Game
of Thrones where they you know introduce
like the Khaleesi Mother of Dragons yeah
yeah all this stuff so it's it's kind of
like that oh that's sick yeah so nailed
that I think I don't know yeah
I feel like that gets real tough if
you're just trying to be like where are
you staying and then you just like how
much time do you have yeah it's just
like you're on the 9-1-1 call and it's
like oh so where are you staying yeah
can you imagine like going through
immigration and being like where are you
where are you embarking from
that makes sense but like we I believe
like we have to change the name I don't
know if I'm making this up but like we
obviously shortened it but no Thai
person calls like the okay
that one they just call it PG most of
the time yeah
yeah that's pretty long yeah it's hard
though because it's just like an
unnatural way to talk I think for most
yes bro Welsh is like why the [__] do
you have so many throw sounds like
what's happening Welsh is the most like
can I buy a vowel please similar like
throttle I mean we have uh but that's
like it we have like uh yumusha which is
like a soft G so it's like a g with like
a thing on it yeah yeah but like those
are some of the sounds but we don't have
like like anything like that she's like
well it's just like double dollars
looks like the kind of the sides like
talking that's that's a crazy thing yeah
that's cool because you're like right
there next to England yeah yeah that's
what makes it crazy we were around
before English no I know crushing it I I
didn't do it then we didn't crush it
well I know but it's still like crazy
that you know it's the it's the common
language and you're like so close and
you have like insane sounds that just
sounds so different they really thought
to keep it around I'm kind of glad they
did because you know compared to it's
it's a lot more prevalent in Wales than
it isn't say like how Gaelic is an
island or uh and same in Scotland it's
yeah there's a lot more speakers and
it's taking a lot more seriously I think
it's really cool I mean I think
Traditions I think is like the more grow
older and especially being in Japan the
more I think there are some traditions
that if you try to like go with you know
uh if you try to like lose some
tradition to be more accommodating
sometimes you can lose you can lose a
lot of charm yeah that name gotta change
though that name yeah that needed a
chance
I I like uh Japan the way it is
um why am i gatekeeping Japan
yeah
you've reached the final stage of like
weeabooism now you're like no no no I
think I'm basically Japanese at this
point they should they should definitely
like you know the ease of access if you
want to like you know fix the the Aging
population problem like you have to have
immigration of course yeah well that's
gonna be hard to get votes yeah yeah
which is crazy when you think about it
like but you know they
like integration is definitely a a
component in a multicultural world and I
feel like Japanese people do not give a
[__] about that no no they're just like
oh you're not gonna integrate I don't
give a [__] [__] you yeah I don't even
want you here so